Leonardo DiCaprio and Nina Agdal are
okay following a car crash on Saturday
we got a lot going on a source close to
the 24 year old model tells ET all is
okay it was nothing serious et has
obtained the police report from the East
Hampton village police and we're told
there was no transport to the hospital
in either vehicle and I witnessed
details the accident to ET it happened
on Saturday just after 4:30 Leo was
driving a Range Rover he and Nina were
joined by two others the group was stuck
in heavy traffic when a Mini Cooper ran
into the back of Leo's vehicle off
Montauk Highway
Leo looked like he was in shock he went
over to the other vehicle motioned for
the female passenger to exit her car and
guided her to the sidewalk before he
called 911 we're told both Nina and Leo
seemed really shaken up and our
eyewitness adds Leo was comforting Nina
while they were waiting for the police
to get there after an hour they returned
to the car and continued driving to
their destination in East Hampton
you